[Musique]
tutorat faux
l'histoire
écouter le silence
hier
[Musique]
je pense que tous ses états prêteurs et
est heureux pour trop jeune pour avoir
connu un beau diable live with écouter
mais là ils étaient à leur place y
harmonium serge fiori ce matin ne le
regrette absolument pas j'en suis
persuadée d'avoir dit oui à ce qu'on
rende hommage hier soir harmonium
c'était spectaculaire avec oui la
présence en montage vidéo de céline dion
sur scène c'était le chef simon leclerc
qui dirigeait et au sein de l'orchestré
symphonique de montréal toutes sortes
d'interprètes de témoignages c'était
beau de voir les membres d'ammonium dans
la salle regarder leur hommage très ému
c'est beau de voir sir fille aurait
aussi que dû s'y prendre à deux fois
pour faire son discours de remerciement
première fois trop ému il nous a dit je
vous avais préparé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire j'y arrive pas prise de
il a pu vraiment exprimer toute sa
reconnaissance qu'on a travaillé comme
les malheurs jouer nue et ça a donné
so on se retrouve là maintenant et c'est
la même chose pour se rendre compte que
c'est pas où vous ne vous envelopper
dans l'ombre
finalement ce qui t'as vu c'est que
c'est vous qui nous ont appelés
[Applaudissements]
très sensible est-ce que je devrais dire
que c'était une année d'hommes à l'adisq
cette année on dit c'est l'année où
berlinois mais c'est une année donne
parce qu'on a remis aux trophées hier
soir un seul trophée à une femme
et c'était dans la catégorie interprète
féminine de l'année dans votre nom en
nomination et avec isabelle boulay de
bil in chouette andriana mallette
il y avait également clos pelgag et
guylaine tanguay s'est clos pelgag
gagner ce seul trophée décerné à une
femme l'année dernière c'est la première
femme en 25 ans a gagné le trophée
hauteur au compositeur alors on peut
dire en quelque sorte que c'est une
pionnière pour ce qu'il interprète
masculin de l'année pour une deuxième
année consécutive le trophée a été
décerné à patrice michaud patrice
michaud tu as eu à une autre année
spectaculaire qu'il le veut prendre une
pause et voir où l'inspiration voulons
mener le seul trophée qui a échappé à
hubert le noir hier si celui-là est âpre
est masculin de l'année puisqu'il en a
gagné trois pour chanson de l'année pour
la chanson fait de personnes de
révélation de l'année et album pop
il avait ce mot à dire à ses détracteurs
ceux qui trouvent que je suis différent
qui disent que shu et j'aimerais leur
dire que c'est toujours une question de
perception
puis au nom de la jeunesse québécoise
sûr que vous êtes voit qu en est-il
merci ça veut dire ou alors on est au
wok ou on et wac dont on est au bois ou
que ça veut dire qu'on est allé
retourner pour l'avant-garde on est
réveillé quand on est wac
on n'est pas notre affaire on n'est pas
ouvert donc en génération plus vieille
le message qu'ils lançaient leur bac
louis josé houde et lui il était pour
une 13e année consécutive y avait répété
ce monologue d'ouverture là pendant des
mois il nous disait je les ai dans mon
corps et c'était absolument vrai car
elle atteint 2 gagnants qui terminent
leur dise qu'on est qu'ils ne savent pas
dans quelle direction partir
merci beaucoup tout le monde bonne
soirée et ses effets pis ce livre
présente alors comme si c'était pas un
secours le canada compte et jardins
potagers l'idée d'une part la carte
parlante et le métier du mandat soit ils
m'agacent voyant facile et il a raison
c'est vrai quand on est à la limite
comme ça il surpris mais voilà ça ça
nous met alors un autre 40 et josé houde
à un prix deux axes animateurs du gala
de l'adisq qui a lepage et yvon
deschamps sur scène
yvon nault rien perdu de son mordant il
avait cette anecdote savoureuse pour
nous avec les jeunes qu'on doit faire
c'est un petit peu comme monsieur
leclerc au premier gala en 79 puisque
guy latraverse il avait convaincu fait
l'extérieur devenir un soldat clair s'il
vous notre offensive où félix monsieur
la clé un garçon un tee shirt pour gérer
des teutons
[Rires]
le mystère de ce trophée effectivement
en hommage à félix leclerc lors du
premier gala 1979 on aura mis un prix
spécial omar elle exclamée effectivement
la statuette comme tels ne nous fait pas
penser à fait d'être clair bref c'était
en 40e gala très réussie dans la
diversité musicale dans la diversité des
générations sur scène beaucoup de place
aux nouveaux talents et un numéro
d'ouverture chanter spectaculaire en 6
minutes 30 secondes on a interprété les
39 chansons qui ont gagné le félix de la
chanson de l'année
on peut l'écouter
[Musique]
jobs
paradis s'est dit
ct
mais de quoi
voir
je suis
je sais je
puisqu'il faut dire puisqu'il faut
parler
debout
deux peines d'amour
que je fais
[Musique]
bonjour
chacun peut
soit
tous ces mots ce n'est sans que des mots
je n'ai pas besoin de vous
[Musique]
du temps
ah ah
[Musique]
attention
tom
ok
tapie
des temps
à